let's pivot as gently or not as we can
to the other news that relates to desean
watson and that was the decision out of
the clear blue sky yesterday of the
houston texans
to agree to terms with quarterback tyrod
taylor a guy who has bounced around was
the starter in buffalo at one time
starter in cleveland until he was
supplanted by baker mayfield starter in
la with the chargers until dr needle
came into the locker room and
and now he's number two on the depth
chart he's the guy behind he's the only
other quarterback they have under
contract now in houston behind desean
watson one year
up to 12 and a half million dollar that
up to implies he's actually going to be
playing the question is will he be
playing there's two ways to look at this
chris one
he's the
the guy who takes over because they've
realized they have to trade to sean or
two he's the
we have protection in the event desean
decides to sit out the whole year and
hey deshawn if you want to sit out
that's fine we're not going to be caught
unprepared we have a guy ready to go if
you're not going to play this [ __ ] i
agree that that's what he is he's an
insurance policy you know for for all
things whether deshawn watson did get
hurt during the year okay we got a good
backup who can run and run the offense
do those type of things tyrod taylor's a
you know a borderline low level starting
nfl quarterback slash one of the top
backups in football okay yeah you end up
desean watson sits out the year
all right hey we got tyrod taylor we'll
be okay he'll manage football games make
plays from that you know every now and
then
uh
hey we've traded desean watson and now
we've even drafted a quarterback
something of that nature right okay well
we don't need that quarterback to play
right now this year we got tyrod taylor
he could play be a bridge gap type of
thing so i i mean it makes sense from
from all angles as far as the houston
texans are concerned it protects them
for every scenario that happens with
desean watson you know and there's
history right david culley was in
buffalo i believe when tyrod taylor was
there he knows the guy so that makes
sense too tyrod taylor very professional
going to go about his business do those
things he's the perfect guy you want for
backup or bridge gap quarterback
whatever that may be uh so that's smart
it's smart by nick casario and the
texans here
if you're tyrod taylor
do you ask tough questions directly or
through your agent about what the end
game is if i'm tyrod taylor yeah i want
to know
am i going to be your guy am i
am i your insurance policy for sean
watson are you going to trade him what's
going on here and and if you trade him
are you going to end up drafting a guy
who
ends up supplanting me at some point
during the season like how do you
envision using me especially if i've got
incentives that pay me up to 12 and a
half million we don't know what the base
is let's say it's the the similar
ballpark on the high end is cam newton
and jameis winston so the base package
let's say it's in the range of five
million how do i make that seven million
if deshawn watson's still here right how
do i make that seven million if you end
up trading in miami and getting the
third overall pick and you draft a
quarterback with the third overall pick
and it's just a matter of time until i'm
sent to the bench no so i know i'd want
to know all that if i'm tyrod taylor i
hear you i just you know do you think
the texans really know the answers to
those questions yet right i mean i think
both of us neither one of us have been
led to believe or led to believe by
anybody we know in the league right now
that the texans have started answering
calls about deshaun watson or anything
about that at least i haven't heard
anything like that from the people i
know and trust around the nfl so they're
still holding strong about desean watson
they're not going to trade him do those
things
i'm i'm sure they tried to be as honest
as they could the one thing i can say
about nick casario he will shoot you
straight and you know i i 12.5 million
for backup quarterbacks pretty damn good
money like you talked about i mean we
got cam newton who's gonna be starting
for a team and you know making less than
that significantly gonna have to earn it
uh but we'll see where this goes either
way but i think it is smart by them and
yeah i don't tyrod just he's at a point
of his career where he can't really call
his shots right he's kind of got to just
go with okay this makes sense for me
this is good money right here 12.5 to be
the backup or even if i am the bridge
gap guy and we'll go from there but
you're right there's still a lot of
different scenarios that could play out
as far as desean watson's trade and
affecting tyrod taylor
that news emerged yesterday afternoon
peter king and i were doing pftpm and my
first reaction was
the texans finally acknowledge they have
a problem yeah now
now i i can't get a clear read my first
thought was this means they're going to
trade him and then as peter and i talked
it through it's like you know they very
well could be
signing tyrod taylor just to sit on him
sean watson yeah hey you wanna you wanna
huff and puff and try to blow our house
down we have protection in the event
that you do that but i think the the
acquisition in and of itself is the
first time we've seen an official
acknowledgement by the texans that
there's a problem because they've been
trying to play this i don't know what
you're talking about right that's what
david culley did last thursday with that
press conference a half hour after his
comments dropped to jim trotter and
steve weish where he says deshawn's our
quarterback right now and laughs about
it yeah but then then it was back to
i've all know i oh well deshawn yeah
he's committed does i don't know
anything about him not wanting to be
here this is acknowledgment by the
texans so at least we know they're
suited and capable
of admitting that there's an issue
but it's still not clear
how this acquisition
fits into their intended path toward
fixing the issue because look there is a
chance that their attitude is going to
be hey screw you we got a contract yeah
we gave you a bunch of money last year
and if you want if you want it between
what you have to pay us back and what
you forfeit if you want to give up more
than 20 million dollars this year we'll
take it we'll happily not pay you the 10
million in salary that you're due to
make this year will happily collect 5
million plus in signing bonus money that
is attributed to this year that you
haven't earned we'll happily collect all
the fines that you would be racking up
to the tune of 50 000 a day for skipping
training camp and then then for each
preseason game the fine is the amount of
a game check right so
hey they they now have the ability to do
it without worrying about josh mccown or
someone else being their starting
quarterback they've got someone who
could come in and do
a a a a good job a good enough job you
know he's not desean watson but he's not
just some and i i don't mean any
disrespect to josh mccown that was just
the first guy i thought of he's not even
under contract anymore but just whatever
slappy they happen to find yeah i got
you and say you're our quarterback it's
an undrafted guy out of you know central
michigan or something that this is a guy
who's played in the nfl taking a team to
the playoffs this is a credible
replacement for deshawn watson in the
event that watson decides to sit out the
whole year and the texans decide not to
trade him no i mean yes it definitely is
and and you know that
you know with the fact of the lawsuit
and those things that you know are have
been filed and we haven't seen yet
you know it it does force desean watson
a little bit into a spot here too where
you know again conspiracy chris there
wants to go oh well maybe they're taking
away all his options to be traded
they're kind of forcing them into a
corner here to be like hey the texans
are still here we still like you during
all this tough times and things like
that i don't know but either way it's a
smart decision by tyrod taylor and
yeah or and look look i hey hey i
yeah if i represented desean watson
right
in this yeah there would be many things
that i would immediately be attempting
to explore and there would be various
legal paths that i would be
ready to pursue if i got the slightest
shred of evidence to support my
suspicions that that
and i just and these are just natural
suspicions we're gonna have because of
tony busby's
connect connection right potential
connection i wanna know what the
connection is yeah and i would
aggressively pursue all avenues
available to me within the confines of
the litigation that apparently hasn't
been filed yet maybe it has or otherwise
to get to the bottom of that uh because
yeah i m look my my approach to
anything like this that makes the
the gut say something may be here you
got to find out you can't just ignore it
you start turning over rocks you start
putting in the elbow grease you start
finding creative ways to get information
and force people to give you documents
text messages communications who did you
talk to who do you know when did you
last talk to him how well do you know
him oh you know him when when well
you've been to his house you know that
kind of stuff i mean i'd want to find
out all that to see whether to what
extent there are tentacles
between the lawyer
and the organization
that and and that's fair right at this
point there's already a tentacle i want
to see how many tentacles there are and
whether or not they had any involvement
directly or indirectly in the situation
that desean watson now faces again these
are all things i would be doing if i
represented the interest of desean
watson yeah no i hear you i mean i mean
the texans got you know they got a lot
of work in front of them there's no
doubt we'll see where this desean watson
conversation goes tyrod taylor was a
smart sign by them but i mean you know
they're they're in total rebuild mode i
mean they really are there's no other
way around it i mean if you really look
look at the moves they've made over the
last few days the signings it's a lot of
you know low level
free agent signings to one and two year
deals right to basically hey a little
depth
will evaluate you throughout the year
maybe
but it's nothing major that they got to
be stuck with because i think they're in
the process of retooling their whole
football team and i think they've kind
of told us that here with some of the
names you see in these one and two-year
deals that they've signed yeah there's
some good players here but not guys you
look at to go oh well he'll be you know
he could be there for the next five or
six years or oh he's definitely going to
start and be the man there no i mean
yeah he might start you know for a year
whatever else
but but it is a total rebuild mode and
and just man now we got this story to
talk about you know on top of all the
other stuff and we'll see where it goes
but uh i i don't expect a whole lot from
this texans football team really with or
without desean watson this year and i i
don't i don't know how they can be all
that good with what you see on paper and
i know we still have more free agency
and draft but man they got a lot of work
in front of them
yeah and uh that that is uh certain and
the challenge is working their way
through the weeds in a way that makes
sense
nick casario is still adjusting to an
organization that i would guess does
things very differently yeah in the
organization he spent a long time with
before coming to houston and how quickly
can he
get things pointed in the right
direction that remains to be seen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports